andrew yang a very intelligent and the
presidential candidate with a lot of
interesting ideas in all kinds of
technological fields tweeted that
because of quantum computing no code is
uncrackable
is he wrong or right he was premature
let's say so well ok wrong look i you
know i i'm actually i'm you know i'm a
fan of andrew yang I like his cat you
know I like his ideas I like his
candidacy I think that uh you know he
you know he may be ahead of his time
with you know the universal basic income
and you know and so forth and he may
also be ahead of his time in that tweet
that you referenced so guarding
regarding using quantum computers to
break a cryptography so the situation is
this okay so the famous discovery of
Peter shor you know 26 years ago that
really started quantum computing you
know as an autonomous field was that if
you build a full scalable quantum
computer then you could use it to
efficiently find the prime factors of
huge numbers and calculate discrete
logarithms and solve a few other
problems that are very very special and
character right they're not np-complete
problems we're pretty further not okay
but it so happens that most of the
public key cryptography that we
currently use to protect the internet is
based on the belief that these problems
are hard okay what sure showed is that
once you get scalable quantum computers
then that's no longer true okay but now
you know uh you know before people panic
there are two important points to
understand here okay the first is that
quantum supremacy the milestone that
Google just achieved is very very far
from the kind of scalable quantum
computer that would be needed to
actually threaten public key
cryptography okay so you know we touched
on this earlier right but Google's
device has 53 physical qubits right you
threaten cryptography your
walking you know with any of the known
error correction method you're talking
millions of physical qubits because
error correction would be required to
yes yes yes yeah yes yeah it's a a it
certainly would right and uh you know
how much you know how great will the
overhead be from the error correction
that we don't know yet but with the
known codes you're talking millions of
physical qubits and of a much higher
quality than any that we have now okay
so you know I I don't I don't think that
that is you know coming soon although
people who have secrets that you know
need to stay secret for 20 years you
know are already worried about this you
know for the good reason that you know
we presume that intelligence agencies
are already scooping up data you know in
the hope that eventually they'll be able
to decode it once quantum computers
become available okay so so there is so
so so so this brings me to the second
point I wanted to make which is that
there are other public key cryptosystems
that are known that we don't know how to
break even with quantum computers okay
and there's so there's a whole field
devoted to this now which is called post
quantum cryptography okay and so there
is already so so we have some good
candidates now the best-known being what
are called a lattice based crypto
systems and there is already some push
to try to migrate to these crypto
systems so NIST in the u.s. is holding a
competition to create standards for post
quantum cryptography which will be the
first step in trying to get every web
browser and every router to upgrade you
know and use a you know some like SSL
that is would be based on on you know
what we think is quantum secure
cryptography but you know this will this
will be a long process but you know it
is it is something that people are
already starting to do and so so you
know I'm sure as algorithm is was sort
of a dramatic discovery you know it
could be a big deal for whatever
intelligence
agency first gets a scalable quantum
computer if no at least certainly if no
one else knows that they have it right
but eventually we think that we could
migrate the internet to the post quantum
cryptography and we'd be more or less
back where we started okay so this is
sort of not the application of quantum
computing I think that's really going to
change the world
you